good morning Hank it's Tuesday so last
week the Bureau of Labor Statistics
announced that in the u.s. in December
the unemployment rate was four point
seven percent close to the lowest it's
been in nine years and fairly close to
the lowest it's been since the early
1970s but you may have also heard that
the real unemployment rate in the u.s.
is six percent or nine point two percent
or twenty percent or even thirty eight
percent and to me this seems like one
example among many of how in our current
political discourse different people are
reaching vastly different conclusions
because they're all looking at different
sets of data and until we can agree on
what the facts are
we can't meaningfully discuss what they
mean let's start with that 38% number
this refers to the labor force
participation rate which is a measure of
how many Americans over the age of 18
are either working or actively looking
for work now as you can see this rate
has declined quite a bit over the last
20 years from over 67 percent to under
63% but by far the biggest reason for
this decline is that Americans are
getting older which means that a higher
percentage of them have retired but even
if you look at the labor force
participation rates of people between
the ages of 25 and 54 that rate has also
declined about 1.5 percent since the
Great Recession and about 3.5 percent
since its height in the late 1990s
what's the deal there well the two
biggest factors seem to be more people
choosing to be full-time parents and
more students in professional and
graduate schools according to the most
recent data 90 of the 95 million
Americans not in the work force say they
do not want a job now but the remaining
5 million people of course is a lot of
people like it's 3 percent of the total
u.s. labor force and some portion of
declining labor participation is
probably due to lack of job
opportunities people might have retired
earlier than they otherwise would have
because they lost a job or they might be
in graduate school but they could be
tempted into the workforce for the right
opportunity etc now smart people
disagree about how much of the declining
labor participation is attributable to
the economy but on its own that
statistic does not tell us much about
unemployment for one thing the labor
force participation rate will continue
to decline as the population continues
to age whether the economy is good or
bad but also if you're going to claim
that the real US unemployment rate is 38
percent that means that back in 1967 it
was 41 percent and that the lowest the
US unemployment rate has ever been
is 33% in 2000 so let's move on to
actual measures of unemployment every
month the US Census Bureau surveys
60,000 households to find out how many
people are out of work and then on the
first Friday of every month they release
six different unemployment rates because
nothing is ever easy but for our
purposes only four of the matter
first you have u3 which is the official
unemployment number it includes all
adult civilians who are without work and
have looked for a job within the last
four weeks that's the number that's
currently four point seven percent then
you have u4 which adds in so-called
discouraged workers people who are
without jobs but have stopped looking
for work because they don't believe
there are any jobs they can get adding
them in raises the current unemployment
rate to 5% and then u5 adds in so-called
marginally attached workers who are
people who want to be in the workforce
but haven't recently sought jobs because
they're taking care of family
responsibilities or taking classes and
they bring the unemployment rate up to
5.7 percent and then lastly u6 includes
people who work part-time but want to be
working full-time including them brings
the current unemployment rate to 9.2
percent
so which of these is the real
unemployment rate well it depends on
what you're trying to measure the u3
number is useful for one thing because
it's closely aligned with international
standards which allows us to compare our
unemployment rate to that of other
countries like in Brazil a similar
measure has the unemployment rate at 12
percent in Germany it's 4.1 percent in
Spain it's 19 percent but the u6 number
is also useful because it helps us to
understand how much so-called slack
there is in the labor market that is how
much room there is for job growth as you
can see you 3 and u6 basically track
together but there are slight
differences like the distance between
you 3 and u6 is currently slightly
higher than it was before the 2009
recession indicating that there may be
more room for job growth than the u3
number would have us conclude the most
important thing though is that when
talking about our unemployment rate we
can't compare oranges with grapefruits
and unfortunately that's happening a lot
in our political conversations right now
you might hear for instance that at the
height of the recession unemployment was
10% and now it's only down to nine point
two percent but that's mixing
unemployment measures if the
unemployment rate is currently nine
point two percent it was 17% at the
height of the recession and if it was 10
percent of the recession speak it is
currently four point seven percent by
either measure the unemployment rate in
the United States is lower than the
average is
since World War two but it's still
somewhat higher than full employment but
of course that's only part of the
picture because people don't just need
jobs they need good ones on that front
the recovery from the recession is
probably still unfinished median
household incomes are likely still lower
than they were in 2007 although we don't
have the final data for 2016 yet so in
summary no matter how you measure it US
unemployment is low but could be lower
and median household income is rising
but not yet to all-time high and if we
can agree on these facts maybe we can
move forward with a discussion about how
to continue or even expand this economic
recovery okay not American nerdfighters
I am sorry that this was such an
American video but we're having just a
smidge of a political discourse crisis
over here let me know in comments with
non American topics I could cover next
week to make it up to you okay Hank I'm
off to go see the movie hidden figures
for a second time because I liked it
that much maybe also let me know in
comments what your favorite Oscar
contending movies are my favorites are
hidden figures in moonlight hey thanks
for keeping the employed all these years
I'll see you on Friday